[Musique]
antoine de maximy sera au cinéma le
grenier à sel vendredi 4 septembre à
20h45
il viendra présenter son film j'aimerais
mourir dans les carpates on connaît tous
antoine de maximy puisque ça fait 15 ans
qu'ils présentent
j'irai dormir chez vous et il a décidé
d'en faire une fiction où quelque chose
se passerait mal et donc on suit
l'enquète il y à sa monteuse qui est
temps qu'à rester en france qui récupère
ses vidéos et elle fait une enquête pour
retrouver en tête de maximy qui a
disparu dans les carpates
alors on connait tous en train de maximy
on connait tous ces chemises rouges
il viendra au grenier à sel pour nous
montrer sa chemise rouge ces caméras et
nous rencontrer donc vous pouvez
réserver vos places sur notre site
internet cinéma grenier à sel points
comme et je vous dis à vendredi
est-ce que je peux dormir chez vous des
projets c'est quand même très bizarre de
faire ce genre de geste discrètement là
on dirait qu'ils complotent
voyant quitté d'abord vous croyez qu'on
pourrait retrouver
[Musique]